foreign
this is pretty rad I haven't had this
happen yet on the show uh Julia gulia
returns like one week later so I'm gonna
bring her on hey Julia what's up
hey Dr John thank you so much for having
me back of course okay so for everybody
listening
uh it's probably a week or two ago Julia
called in and so your son your you have
a whole history of family stuff but you
are going to see your son's
step family and for Christmas in like
South Dakota or something yeah a little
bit Norther than that okay
it's somewhere where it's cold and
Barren and sad and yes yeah we're going
there and he didn't want to go because
he's 17. and he has a sweet little
girlfriend and he has a new job and so
we talked about what do we do we make
him go not make him go all that okay and
then right Kelly this just now said hey
I have a surprise Julia talked to him
did all the things you said deloney and
now she wants to talk to you again and I
can't I don't even know really what's
this is gonna be awesome okay so what's
up oh man okay so yes I took your advice
and honestly for the first time or one
of the very fast I think an account on
my hand it's a handful of times I have
stuck to my guns with my son I felt good
about what I was asking I felt solid
like yes I am being rational
um I I told them you don't get a vote
but you get input like you said
and um I said you know we'll go work out
and we'll do some things that you've
enjoyed too and I felt really confident
and I didn't even second guess myself
how did it go really good
you know it didn't really go that great
yes he he definitely pushed back which I
was expecting
he did it did soften the blow somewhat
when I took your advice and gave him
some control over how we spend our time
there so that did help but it did not
really go well he um we kind of thought
about it but again I just said you know
what you don't get a vote you don't get
a vote I just kept repeating that and
um and a couple couple days went by and
I've been asking him to take the time
off of work for those few days for
several weeks before we even spoke
um hoping that he would and
um a couple days go by after we had the
talk and he told me that he was
unsuccessful getting the time off work
because he didn't ask early enough oh
what a great Flex hey right you raised a
very smart young man well played like
I'm tipping line I definitely did
I just I yeah I was uh half mortified
half like wow that's impressive so um
honestly if it had been my kid I would
high-fived him like well played
uh you know and I I've been really
thinking oh I know and I've been
thinking a lot about all of this and
um you know I I don't remember I know we
talked about a lot but I raised him as a
single mom and
um I really my entire or his entire life
I've had a hard time telling him no
because I just thought I brought this
child into the world with no without two
parents and early on I decided that I
was going to try to give him everything
he wanted in spite of that and I think I
really messed up I really do I I don't
and so I've always given in to him and
um
at this point I don't really know how to
differentiate between
normal teenage boy behavior and
and my own expectations if they're
normal if they're rational
and then we have this other history of
me really having a hard time saying no
to him because
that's just where I'm at and
here we are yeah so I
sounds like he's he's received a vote
he's got to vote his whole life
so this is this is a
this is something he doesn't have the
maybe not even have a psychological
wiring for
right I know yeah I know that's okay
it's all right he's gonna face us at
some point and it's better that he face
it from you than his first boss or from
a college professor that fails him
because he you know whatever right um
and so he's gonna he's it's the the Day
of Reckoning is coming
um okay in or actually it's here uh and
you've got you've got Glimpse number one
so you know and I think I don't remember
I told you this there's no chance that
talk goes well
in terms of I think it goes well and you
said what you need to say you said it in
a way you just say it it doesn't go well
where he leans back and he goes gee mom
you're right
your job is to raise it a great man and
that means you have to say no sometimes
you're right it went to no man me and
girlfriend have already figured out how
she's gonna sneak over to the house
while you're gone and I'm gonna make all
this money and so it was just a a
complete
his plans blew up and they never blew up
because he gets to decide everything
that happens in his life so yeah here he
is um and so I'm gonna think through
this out loud is that cool
absolutely yes yeah
um
here's Avenue number one
is this the hill you want to die on
is this and what I mean by that is he's
gonna have to learn this
is this the one
um or
is there another one like I don't I
don't know what the next step is is he a
senior in high school or a junior
he's a junior so I'll still have a year
I'm at home okay that actually actually
makes a difference
um
foreign
right now
right or do you if you back off of this
one because you're pretty Resolute this
time
if you back off of this one does he go
exactly like always I think right right
so you kind of drew a line in the sand
and he just smiled at you and stepped
across it
and uh
the second one is I don't think where
does he work
he works at Chick-fil-A yeah I don't
think they'll fire him I really don't
especially if he walked in and said
um
I absolutely blew it I was supposed to
take time off to go be with a family
situation that I didn't want to be a
part of and I messed up but I have to go
on this thing and I really value this
job
right I agree with you yeah I don't
think they will fire him they might
because they have to but I've just done
some work behind closed doors with that
company for a couple years and they are
of the highest caliber of Integrity
especially when a young when it comes to
raising young people
um the third option is which this is
kind of the nuclear option is you tell
him I'll go with you
and I will sit with you when you tell
your supervisor or your lead manager
whatever they call them there that you
didn't take the time off this is a
non-negotiable trip and that you hope
they don't fire him but you understand
if they have to let him go
right
and you will look like the word he he
again he's going to look at you not out
of anger he's it will be bewilderment he
doesn't know you no he doesn't you know
what I mean I know I know
um and so
he's a hundred percent age appropriate
there's not one thing he's doing that
makes me like oh no
um he's never had a boundary and you put
one up
and of course he's gonna run into it and
see if it falls down see if there's a
way around it'll wait over it can't go
under it right he's that's his that's
his job he's 17.
right
um
what you have to be prepared for is he
goes to war
right
I don't know how to I don't know how to
to do that I don't
um but I definitely feel Resolute in
this
um because I feel like if I don't do it
now
like you mentioned before he's going to
face it some other time or I'm not going
to be there to help him and to counsel
him and it's going to come from left you
know from from Left Field
um and I feel like I've already wasted
or spent a lot of his youth not helping
him with this skill have you told him
what you just told me
I haven't no I think that's a good
conversation to have
and he's not he's not going to
understand it but he'll hear it
okay he'll think it's just I mean part
of him it you'll be a Charlie Brown's
teacher
yes and part of it is hey the world's
Coming For You at a thousand miles an
hour and you don't even realize it yet
right and because I loved you so much
and I didn't want you to hurt so bad I
protected you from a lot more than I
probably should have and I'm not going
to apologize for it because a it's over
and B I did it out of love even though I
did it I would probably do it
differently this time
all I can control is what happens next
but when I say go to war
it wouldn't surprise me if you came into
like my office at the local University
and you came in and
he starts doing drugs
he sneaks out
he runs away and goes to his
girlfriend's house to try to avoid going
on this trip like none of that would
would be shocking Behavior to me
okay that's good to know okay I mean
it's you still gotta you still may have
to call the police to go find him you
still may have to get a coach or another
Mentor that that is in his life that can
help out but not any response he has to
these boundaries
um isn't going to surprise me
I I would default as best I can and
again I talk too much you listen to the
show you know that
um I I err on the side of over
explaining
okay
I can do that and it may be as simple as
man
I will help you when we get back I'm
gonna help you find another job if they
fire you I'll help you okay right you
know what I mean and that's kind of just
like a weird what like but I'll I'll
help you
um and I'm happy to go up there and do
it but I think the right thing for you
to do is to go let your supervisor know
that you you
forgot to ask off or you didn't ask off
soon enough and you blew it but this
family trip was mandatory
right and it's again it's a hard hard
lesson it's a hard lesson
um
but if this is one you want to stick to
on your stick to your guns on
um
and then you got you got my support in
my vote
thank you I don't want there to be an
illusion that it's going to be like all
right you got me
I you know I don't I don't think yeah no
I I don't think for a moment that's how
it's gonna go
um I keep wishing for that
but uh yeah I I've been through enough
now
um
but this time I'm not giving in I'm not
I can't for his benefit I can't keep
telling myself that yeah this is for his
benefit and
just with your help and I'm confident in
sticking with this and you know I
believe it's gonna go okay I do so and
maybe at the end the way out of the gate
is
um put two or three or four nice
restaurants
on the table and say where which one do
you want you get to pick where we go
tonight
okay because and you could tell them
we're gonna have Mom and we're gonna
have mom talk number two
and he'll roll his eyes and be like
rolling big rolling big or even set it
up beforehand hey I want you to go ahead
before I even say anything I want you to
roll your eyes as much as you can do it
do it do it perfect and make him do it
and do it with him and
then say Hey you get to pick two or
three restaurants because we're going on
Mom and son Talk number two and I'm
already telling you you're not gonna
like it this is part of being my son and
you know what I'm saying like it was
just gonna set the stage but also we're
quietly kind of through the side door
we're giving him some choice
and he can choose to go talk to a
supervisor he can choose to have you go
with him he can choose to quit but he
doesn't have to choose whether he goes
on a trip or not
is that fair
it is fair and can I say one more thing
can you say anything you want
well
I just want to let you know that I
completely agree with you
bro is the best Rock ballad ever yes
hey I'm gonna I don't want you to say
your kid's name on here listen young man
your mom's brilliant
she's very smart listen to her
you just Julia it's on you Julie you
just made my whole my whole week isn't
that song incredible I get goosebumps
amazing I used to push play alone in my
room and just stare up at the ceiling
and listen to it over and over
and it's still a rock to this day I mean
and when I heard you say that I
literally had to rewind the podcast I
was like wait what listen everybody yeah
Skid Row I Remember You I want you to
get in your car put your headphones on
get in a quiet private place and listen
to that song alone and if you don't
start crying you don't have a soul ah so
good Julia you are the best of the best
of the best
this will be hard
I wish I could tell you it's going to be
not hard it's going to be simple moving
forward it's gonna be really challenging
one last thing I would recommend Julia
you have one or two women that you trust
that you can reach out to when you're
about to cave in
you have one or two or three men that
you trust that your son trusts that you
can reach out to that they can go to
coffee they can talk they can go to
Cracker Barrel Waffle House whatever
um go for a walk or a hike or a run that
he can just complain about you and be
like she's just all of a sudden and and
they can say yeah you're exactly right
because your mom's
um overnight the light came on and she's
seeing a fuller picture of your life and
um
world's coming at you real real fast
and Mom is no longer going to be able to
stand in the way
he is lucky lucky lucky to have you and
um you're an inspiration to all of us
parents who have realized ah we need to
make some changes and these changes are
gonna be real real hard
and the adult thing to do is to make the
hard changes anyway